[Music]
hey this is an interview with the
authors of the alpha code paper by
deepmind this is a crazy system it does
automated competitive programming and is
about as good as an average human in
real competitions which is crazy in case
you haven't seen it i've made a
comprehensive paper review of this paper
in the last video so be sure to check
that out because the authors that i'm
interviewing today have also seen that
video and we're able to dive right into
the matter answering any questions any
criticisms and so on you're also able to
get a behind-the-scenes look into what
things went wrong during this research
things that didn't work out things that
were red herrings and much more we also
talk about how the project came to be
and how the authors dealt with the
immense media reaction that followed the
release let me know how you like these
types of videos having the authors on is
a huge privilege and i'm absolutely sure
you'll learn something useful from this
conversation if you like content like
this don't forget to leave a like
subscribe tell me what you think in the
comments and i'll see you around bye bye
yeah hi everyone welcome back i'm here
today with remy leblanc and peter choi
who are authors of the competition level
code generation with alpha code paper
i'm just going to call it the alpha code
paper everyone's excited about this
paper it's so much hype around it and
it's very cool to have the authors with
me so remy and peter thank you very much
for being here thanks for having us hey
thanks a lot for having us yeah we're
quite happy to be doing this with you
today
so the the paper uh obviously you know
given that the machine learning
community and the programmer community
intersect in large parts um and then the
competitive programming scene also is is
kind of known for not being the most
humble um
obviously let's say let's say obviously
there was quite a bit of hype quite a
bit of media reception around the paper
um did you expect anything like this and
and how did you experience sort of how
the paper was received in public um i
guess i can take that one first let's
start this pizza um
so i think overall we've been fairly
happy with how the paper has been
received right uh it's uh
people have been talking a lot about the
ideas that we put forward and and the uh
the results that while we think it's
fairly impressive for what we're trying
to do is is nowhere near what it might
have been reported
in some news outlets
so we we did expect that there was going
to be
positive reactions negative reactions
and
a bit of misunderstandings probably uh
but i think overall uh we've been we've
been fairly happy
yeah i think um we
we spent like a few a few hours maybe
even like a day or two after we released
the paper just kind of watching with
popcorn what was going on
um
and yeah that was pretty enjoyable um
but
yeah overall i'd say i'm pretty pleased
do you want to maybe just um as an
opportunity to
do did you hear like cross-over
statements you said you know some people
said a bit you know a bit more than what
you actually did so um do you is there
something that you saw that was like
really where you say no this is actually
this is wrong this is too much you know
rather than just selling it very
prettily anything you sort of want to
bring down to earth i think i can
definitely add one thing there i think
the biggest thing that i noticed and
like quite a common mistake was
to like overstate our result as
deep mind
you know has an algorithm which is as
good as an average programmer but like
really the right answer is um it's
average competitive you know we get the
same results as an average competitive
programmer um and those are like huge
huge there's a huge difference there
um
but you know that distinction can be
like a bit nebulous if you're not
familiar with with programming or
competitive programming and so that's
the one the main thing i think would
become the top of my list yes of course
like
most of the most of your job as a as a
software programmer isn't actually
writing code right it's
reading code understanding code thinking
about
how to achieve whatever it is you want
to achieve right so we focus on a much
much narrower scope
in this paper where we have a very
precise description of what we want to
do we have examples we have constraints
etc
which which to us is a very interesting
proxy for problem solving
but it's very far from the full job of
an actual developer
yeah i i was i mean i was
i think even with the
with the correcting the record it is
still very impressive and i think before
we before the recording we talked about
that also you seem to have
uh been a bit surprised at how far you
were able to get with this system could
you tell us a little bit about the just
the process of you know how did you
start out what did you do i mean i've
used for example codex or copilot from
github and i have to say it's like is
really good like it's uh
i think it's it's a game changer if the
ui is is cleaned up a little bit and
models like this
um
will be you know i think assisting
programmers a lot but how did you go
from like that were you even aware of of
codex co-pilot and how how did you get
to to alpha code and and what did you
expect
right so i think
and i mean i wasn't there from the very
beginning of the of the problem but
i think we've always been focusing on a
slightly different
approach than that what codex and
co-pilot
are doing i think we're really
interested in this aspect of problem
solving and we were really interested in
this aspect of generalization like we
wanted to solve unseen problems and come
up with novel solutions to things that
the model hadn't seen
during training
um and so competitive programming was
sort of a of a natural target
for that and then
we we started getting a bit of traction
and we set ourselves what we thought to
be
almost an impossible goal uh but we
thought we needed to be ambitious to
really truly push ourselves and push the
uh push the methods
and so our level of confidence in
whether or not we're going to achieve
this uh fluctuated during during the
course of the project
uh at some some points we had high
points and we had low points some points
were convinced we were going to succeed
at some points uh we had uh pretty
severe doubts but uh yeah in the end
then we managed to get uh all the way
across the finish line i think one one
thing i'd add to that is um i think this
is the the first project where
i the press project i've worked on which
had like
quite a strict adherence to you know
looking at a particular metric quite
regularly
um and i think that that really helped
us
um incorporate ideas that were happening
uh that were you know being being
researched within demand and outside of
deep mind
um
so
yeah i think that like uh that was that
was really worthwhile and um
something that uh we we've learned to
value quite a lot
in working on these like ambitious
problems
it's cool if you if you have some sort
of a north star right that of where you
want to get at least you know where you
want to get i think with most projects
it's it's even ill-defined kind of where
where the end goal is and i think yeah
it's probably half the game in in in
academia and also projects as such so um
i've i've made this little overview and
intro to your to your paper did you feel
that was accurate uh is there anything
missing anything you want to amend on on
how the system works any wrong emphasis
that i've set
i i don't think there's anything uh
there's anything wrong with what you
described and i was fairly impressed
that you managed to sort of distill this
this
massive paper down to
a reasonable size in terms of of the
video
um
so yeah no i think i was uh i was quite
happy with the uh with the way you
described it uh this of course uh
opportunities to get into more details
um
by reading the paper itself uh
especially on the maybe on the method uh
section uh but of all it was really good
i was very impressed
as always
yeah generally love your videos yannick
so um so it's a really easy way to
to get like a
an overview of a paper um
and you know decide if you want to read
it yourself at all
um and yeah this is kind of not an
exception
thanks i wasn't i wasn't chasing for
compliments i was actually wondering
wondering if you had something
okay so i think one point of the
contention i think we're all on board
with you know we do some sort of a
pre-training here on on on github we do
some sort of a fine tuning on the
problem we're interested in right which
is these coding problems but then i
think the point of contention that a lot
of people have is this sort of this
approach of large scale sampling
followed by filtering which is really
different than how a human solves
problem this is uh i'm as a programmer i
don't i don't blast out a hundred
thousand different possible solutions
and then you know run them all not even
in my mind right not even that's not
even the way i think to to sort of
sample forward and then test all of
these things i'm actually impressed that
this you know the filtering step would
would give you the sort of the correct
things right here um
so my
my question would be i'm i'm willing
let's say to
to disregard the fact that that's not
mechanically how i do it um i'm willing
to still consider the possibility that
the model will actually you know given
the attention maps and so on actually
does you know
do something worthwhile more than just
kind of a random sampling right um
because if i if it were just a random
sample i would never get a solution
so i'm willing to to see that the model
might be doing something and then i
thought well if that's the case
shouldn't i somehow
find
a representation
of the abstract concepts
inside of the latent spaces somehow you
know when it whenever the algorithm is
about uh sorting lists shouldn't i i
find like list primitives and and
sorting algorithm comparison operators
and something like like the concepts
that i would think of when implementing
this algorithm or like a dijkstra's
nearest neighbor algorithm um
if i if i implement that shouldn't i
find these things have you
thought of like investigating the model
and see whether or not it kind of learns
programming concepts by itself is that
even you know possible
i mean that's a very interesting
question right we've done a lot of
analysis on the model but as we report
in in section six of the paper uh it's
either centered of the on the impact um
at the of the end metric uh like the
solve rates
or
we analyze the sample themselves and
peter's done a great job by the way
showing that our models don't really
copy paste
um but we haven't yet prodded the model
enough internally to be able to answer
that question definitively um
if i had to venture a guess though
i'd say it's very likely that these
concepts are present at the latent space
level and as you just said the best
proof of that is that the model does
actually come up with these relevant
concepts and implements them
um to solve some of the problems right
so we have treater vessels we have
dynamic programs we have sorting uh all
these sort of uh of things so
they're definitely there um
it seems to be very likely that they're
here and uh and yeah
doing massive sampling alone cannot
explain the the soul rate that we have
um i think
another issue though is that probably
the right concepts are there but they're
in there amidst many many other concepts
and picking exactly the right concept at
the right time
is actually really difficult
yeah i think um i probably add something
to that um which is i guess
that maybe the last point that we made
is like not even specific to
to like the transform work that we have
right when i read a competitive
programming problem like i've got like
five ideas in my head of what might work
um so i think there's
you know that wouldn't be that bad even
if there was a bunch of different things
in there
um one other thing i think i'd add is
that
i guess
because we're we sample from the model
auto aggressively right the latents are
actually changing as you you do that um
and so
later on like the model may not have
honed in on the concept of like oh i
need to do a dfs here or i need to do
um doctor's algorithm um until you know
maybe like 50 80 of the way through the
problem so um i think if we were to do
that investigation we'd have to consider
how that changes through the sampling
procedure
yeah it's not even clear where to look
basically is it at the end of the
encoder yeah during sampling
we don't know
yeah it is also i mean it connects to
this larger problem of people people
arguing whether or not these models can
quote unquote reason right and you
explicitly in the paper also uh make an
effort to connect this to abstract
reasoning and so on i think you know
investigating things like this here
could be sort of a proxy uh for for
really demonstrating yes there is
actually something in these models that
amounts to sort of symbolic abstract
reasoning even though we do sort of next
token prediction so i'm yeah it's i
think it's it's fairly fairly cool
i guess um
can i jump in there yet so i just say
like one kind of more general point
there i think is that um
you know i i definitely see this as it's
like clearly different from how i do i
solve a problem um but also i think in
machine learning like maybe
you know the first step to doing
something the right way is doing it at
all um and i think that's that's kind of
you know part of what we've achieved too
do you have plans to bring down this
large scale sampling
like is there is there any are there any
ideas floating around of you know maybe
we don't have to sample a million things
and then and then test them all
i mean i think of course it would be uh
somehow more satisfying if our model
could just like one-shot the problems um
and and i think getting higher quality
average samples is a really interesting
research direction um
especially since yeah every time you
want to solve the problem you probably
don't want to have to try and begin
different things right that's typically
not how how it works but i think there's
also something really interesting in
this scaling uh that we observe
where and the fact that
we can actually get more and more good
answers by simply by something more
is something that's quite interesting to
explore
and what's what's further interesting i
think is that the larger like the model
size seems to be also correlated with
the quality of the samples in itself
which is also something i find cool
yes indeed we see that the bigger the
model
the higher we start and and the uh
the steeper the slope basically in these
sampling curves
so on average the bigger the model the
better the uh
the sample quality
a lot of models have popularized or a
lot of systems in recent times have
popularized this idea of sort of having
an additional model to do filtering
output of generative models right there
is most famously i guess dali which uses
the clip model to to sort of re-rank or
filter the outputs you here have a
rather let's say heuristic way of um of
filtering the outputs is it is it even
possible or considerable that you would
sort of train another model or would
that just shift the problem i'm gonna
guess you know if
training a model that can tell me
whether a program is
correct for a given solution that's
that's almost like solving the problem
itself um
but you know we've seen that
it generally helps to pair generative
models with with rankers is that
something that is in scope here or is
there a particular reason why that
wouldn't work
i think that's a very reasonable
suggestion and over the course of the
project we've tried several ideas that
that are linked to this uh notably
training value functions which
could be used either as guides during
the sampling process or as a ranking
mechanism once the something is done
uh what we've found though is that
learning a good enough value function
remains extremely challenging
and so we're definitely interested in
trying these ideas again
it's just that we haven't been able to
to make them work quite yet and why that
is is uh it's still a bit up for debate
of course we have a small fine-tuning
data set which which might be part of
the reason why or maybe
the action space is too big
we we're still investigating that
yeah i wanted to add something to that
as well which is that
i think uh yeah we definitely tried to
rank a couple of times then um it seems
like you know uh a good thing to try
um
but the way that we you know eventually
did a lot of that filtering was by
executing the program
um and like that is an enormous boost um
and i think
whether we had a ranking model or not we
would like definitely still do that
and there are ways of using the program
execution that like we haven't even
considered right um we just tell we just
use the fact that the public test passes
or doesn't pass
um so i think you know potentially even
continuing to use that or even expanding
on how how that happens
um continued
on how executing the program affects the
filtering and ranking um is also another
kind of interesting i guess non-machine
learning um way to continue doing that
i
i i'm all for non-machine learning like
i'm all for not introducing more models
uh but you do you do point to a good
good good question there is this small
um small set of candidates which comes
from the from this large sets of
potential solutions and the filtering is
a really the really
important step there as you say you
execute the programs against the small
set of samples now this set is
maybe four maybe five test cases or
something like this um
and
i've i haven't seen maybe i've
overlooked that but i haven't seen
anywhere in the paper where did you
investigate you know
if we had 10 such public test cases you
know how does that change or if we just
had one if we
how did how does the success of the
model change with the amount of test
cases you have at your disposal um in
the in the given problem
that's actually a really good suggestion
and we haven't looked at that uh i think
in the end the the issue for us is
we don't really have control over this
quantity yeah and most problems have
very very few uh public test samples
it's between one and three on average i
think
um so we didn't really push this
direction because we thought
we can't move the needle on it uh at
test time
but that doesn't mean that it would be
it wouldn't be informative to try to see
and if i had to take a guess
i would imagine that adding more uh
public tests would be very helpful
because it would make the filtering
mechanism that much more powerful
um
so so yeah that's uh
that's basically how i think about about
this and of course we could try to
generate more tests uh but that's a very
difficult problem
in and of itself
yeah i think um i had another thought on
that which is that um
like i actually would like kind of love
to do that evolation but actually
not necessarily for the problem that we
had because as we said like we can't
control
um the number of public tests we have
but there may be
some
applications of something like alphacode
where you can control the number of
public tests um
and knowing how that affects the ability
of us to to filter the samples would be
super interesting maybe maybe two
samples is enough to get you like
exactly the right solution uh most of
the time
i mean
unit tests come to mind right like
giving you know just programming
essentially by writing four or five unit
tests for for a function or a class that
i want to write and then just let the
model you know come up with a bunch of
examples of for me to choose um
yeah i think that would be that would be
i don't know like the future of
programming looks it looks more and more
something i don't recognize uh from that
i think it's is very exciting uh is
there is there some sort of you know
between between these two is there some
sort of adversarial setup that i could
you have various models like you have a
model that generates new test cases um
but at various stages right so uh
for for the for the clustering you
simply need to execute and observe the
same outputs um
because i'm gonna guess a model that
makes new test cases doesn't necessarily
make correct test cases
but is there is there also a model that
makes test cases just sort of generates
them let's say in a language model way
in a you know most likelihood way did
you ever think of some kind of
adversarial setup given that deep mind
is a lot of in the space of like self
play and
and sort of this this reinforcement
learning setting is there opportunities
here for sort of systems to to challenge
each other to get better
yeah that's it's very funny that you
mentioned that because the
project started off
right after the the alpha star project
basically
um and so we had our our minds were full
of these types of ideas right and so
that's something i've actually been uh
very keen on since the inception of the
project more than two years ago uh to
bring some notions of self-play
curriculum learning etc i think that
that would be very exciting
unfortunately
generating new problems uh is an
extremely difficult task because first
off your problems need to make sense
they need to actually be solvable right
so i can definitely see a world where we
have with many many problems and then
either they're way too difficult or
they're nonsensical
um
and the other thing is we also have to
come up with unit tests that that uh
work with the description of the problem
right
and we have we have a data set of
uh
12 to 13 000 problems uh if i remember
correctly
um which which
is probably not enough for us to train a
really good generative uh model to to
ask problems
um so we we haven't uh we haven't really
tried uh up until now
yes um maybe
i think
one distinction i think is relevant
there is that you know in alpha star and
then a couple of other um self-play
setups they are symmetric
um so you kind of expect the both sides
to be improving all the time whereas um
in in our case you know there's
um it's less obvious how you might
improve the the problem maker over time
is there maybe there's a i have no clue
how these problems are actually made
because humans need to make these
programs right if i look at a a problem
problem description like this i'm like
this is this is insane and not only is
it
very thorough right
also i have to somehow make sure that i
as a maker of the problem don't make a
mistake and when i generate test cases
usually you know for the example inputs
right here are kind of small but then i
need to test like all the edge cases
right to to make sure people have the
correct algorithm which means some are
going to be very long and so on so i
almost have to write like a generator
for you know these these long things
maybe there's a maybe there's a way to
replicate that process of like how
humans come up with these problems as
because they're going to have like
strategies and and what no they just
they don't just sit there and go like
well
backspace right um i don't know have you
looked into do you know how these
problems are made like on a mechanical
level
uh so i think we've been focusing a lot
on the
the solving aspect of things
and a lot less than the generating from
the aspect of things
um i have i have a healthy respect for
uh
the difficulty to generate problems that
people can actually solve right i
remember taking exams and thinking uh
this is no fun and then
i know a lot of people who are teachers
who have to actually devise exams i
think wow this is even less fun actually
um
but yeah i don't think we have a really
good grasp on the human generative
process for this thing we would be
really interesting to discuss with uh
with problem makers to try to
see what are the strategies and whether
or not we can try to replicate that and
and
one possible direction would be to
actually help them um that would be
quite cool yeah i think that's uh
sorry
i think that's a great idea actually
like i i'm really quite interested to go
and like ask them myself now i think
um
maybe like if i had to do i would look
in a computer science textbook and for
like algorithms and then dress them up
in some kind of story that seems to be
like what what a lot of the problems are
um but yeah in terms of doing it
mechanically maybe
that would be even harder than
generating the solutions because
like lots of people upload their
solutions to github but
i guess
i expect there would be less data on how
to create problems
yeah um yeah i was i was exactly i was
more
thinking of there there must be some
process because also these these people
have to come up with new and new
problems right and there's only so many
algorithms and and something like this
backspace problem it's very intricate
right there is not really like an
algorithm that i can just poof apply
like i really have to think through
stuff um one of my questions is that
you hear the test cases the public test
cases they're they're kind of samples
right for you also to think through as a
human um but very often
the the testers they also want to test
not only whether you have the correct
algorithm but also whether you have the
sort of correct runtime algorithm
because you know i can write an
algorithm you know in in i don't know
like if i have an o of n squared um that
might not be the algorithm the tester is
looking for so they want like the o n
log n i'm having trouble writing the the
o n log n algorithm right because
because one is really easy to implement
and one is actually the challenging one
so they will make deliberately like very
large hidden test cases
so that my my naive algorithm would
either go out of memory or out of time
on the evaluation server and this is
something that you would not capture
with just filtering on the public test
cases as as your algorithm does your
algorithm would think well i've solved
the problem right i've come up with a
solution
the naive solution would probably even
be the more likely one given the
language model
and then right and then it's it's
filtering its clustering is like well
all of this seems just fine right uh how
do you have any grasp on how good you
are on these types of problems and and
is your model does it have some strategy
to overcome that
uh yeah i think i can take that um
the the main answer here is that we just
don't we just don't do it
um
we
when we're actually like looking at what
our real self rate is we had to do a lot
of sort of manual checking of solutions
to check that they were meeting the
asymptotic complexity requirements of
that we expected the problem
to actually have
um
i think
you
did you mentioned um
before the call or in your question
about clustering to buckets by by time
of memory i think you wrote that down in
the name um
did you have this in the paper or was
this something i came up with i don't
know that's something that you came up
with okay yeah about it
yeah is this i mean is this is this
viable or is this like a bad idea or
yeah i guess i just had a thought on
that i i think it's um
quite a cool idea um
maybe
that particular implementation of
looking at time and memory usage of of
inputs like definitely is in the theme
of you know executing the program and
and seeing what happens so i think an
idea along that lines is is actually
worth a go
um one thing i would say is that a lot
of these problems i i think
um when you write the solution which is
asymptotically better usually has like a
big constant factor in front of it or a
constant additive um complexity so you'd
have to kind of consider that
um
and whether that is going to
adversely affect which solutions you're
you're removing maybe you're removing
the thing which actually is it's going
to have eventually the acetonic um
lower complexity
i think we could
probably use it to cluster
right because
they've had different if you had the
same
different asymptotic implementation you
would have different uh different values
but choosing directly according to
um like trying to rank them um
depending on their performance on very
very small uh unit tests
would probably i mean my intuition and
our intuition i guess is is that
um we have to be extremely careful uh
how we do that and not to overfit too
much to that particular metric
um
so something that i want to point out
though is that
yes uh sometimes we have what we call
slow positives uh which are correct uh
except that they're they're
impractical
but still
uh i already find that to be quite
impressive uh because some of these
problems we go for the naive approach
but it's not completely evident that the
dave approach would even work right so
we there's this thing like you want to
i remember a
coding mentor
told me about just make it run make it
right make it fast right so we make it
run and we make it right
now all we'll have to do is to make it
fast which admittedly is a really
difficult problem
i think yeah i think i wouldn't be too
worried that the clustering might not
work i would be more worried that the
language model itself might not even you
know might just jump on the sort of more
likely naive implementation and never
actually get to to output the
the very different um possibly more
efficient implementation because these
two things they don't often look similar
they often look very very different from
each other
and yeah
yes i think another issue is
in our pre-training sets on on github
open source code
probably
uh very very fast uh
efficient programming isn't the majority
of what's on there so it might be that
there's a bias towards
simpler more naive uh solutions already
when we start fine tuning so of course
we had we'd have to uh to fight against
that but
um with with respect to
the the sampling and whether or not you
can output something you have a lot of
tricks to increase your your sampling
diversity uh one of the one of the most
notable things is that you have this
this prefix right here which i found
quite quite genius i think in general
the where is the the approach of
including sort of unknown things like
that you would only know at training
time like things about your labels into
the prompts and then having that as sort
of like a dial where you can control the
model i think that is that's a very cool
very cool idea and i think you've shown
quite
quite
uh
impressively how that can help and you
use it mostly to you use it to to
vary the
outputs of your model
but that brings me like
given that we have to
do all of these things to increase
diversity do you think
maybe where our sampling procedure as
such isn't a very good one
because we have to do all these tricks
like could we fundamentally
remake our language models or our
generative models to to be more like
diverse let's say
yeah so i do think
you're right and we're not equipped with
the right tools just yet uh right now we
have this very crude setting to tune
which is the sampling temperature
um but this means that we have very
little control over how qualitatively
diverse our samples are going to be
right so
uh we're searching over the model
distribution in an extremely crude way
which is basically pointing it into a
general direction and say okay
try to take as many sample points as you
can
in that particular direction but it
seems important to me that
we should be able to branch out in
different directions only at fairly
select decision points
not on every step
and we don't have a uh proper mechanism
to do that so
we had high hopes for takei and nuclear
sampling or for
uh our sampling being guided by uh by a
value uh but as we were put in the paper
these didn't really bring
significant improvements
um and i think another thing here is
that we are sampling very independently
right we're not taking past samples into
account
when something a bit more other
aggressively at the level of samples
could probably be a
an interesting
an interesting thing to explore
yeah i had
one
another point there which like
since we we sample from like the models
water regressively um
maybe this isn't really related to the
diversity point but to something in
general um like that's clearly not how i
do things at all when i'm writing code
right
uh i usually write something i write a
sketch and then i like kind of iterate
over it uh i mean kind of random bits of
the code um so it's possible that that
also um is something that needs to sort
of fundamentally change um about the way
that we solve for models
i haven't looked much at
so the
outputs the model generates are
which astounded me like you know just
seeing this and and seeing it output
from a language model is astounding by
itself but also it's very instructive
right and on the right you even you even
do a little bit of analysis and say you
know these lines are this these lines
are this these lines are this um is this
did you generally find that throughout
your solutions i haven't looked at many
more solutions to be honest did you
generally find that code is
interpretable
you know very very sort of instructive
or is this a particular problem that
you've picked out and and to show kind
of like oh look the model solves the
problem in an understandable way or did
you was most of the output cryptic or or
ex understandable
uh yes i think um i looked at a fair few
uh
in you know individual solutions when i
was doing the analysis for this paper
um and i think in general um
so actually to be clear like we did
definitely pick this example
um as something that you know
illustrates what's going on
but in general
you know
the model
does produce things which you can read
and understand what's going on um
i think
you have to
you know and and that's kind of expected
in a way because we're training on human
data right like
we're training to to mimic the way
that human programs look um so that's
not not crazy but um when we fine-tune
um
competitive programmers write very
unreadable code um so that's another
thing to bear in mind
um they will use a lot of typedef in c
plus plus for example
a lot of crazy helper functions
um and that's also something you see a
lot in some of the solutions you'll see
these like huge copy pastes
um of code which like passes an input in
an efficient way
um a lot of that is dead code and it
doesn't actually get used uh and that's
consistent with some of the competitive
programming like real real solutions
um
but
uh yeah i guess like in this you know
maybe it's because we filter for uh
public tests as well like in particular
the solutions which are correct um seem
to be fairly interpretable and and make
sense
um
but yeah on rare occasions like the
implementation is
is quite difficult to understand
um
but yeah i think if you want to um look
into that a bit more and we do have a
tool
um alphacode at dmin.com which which
remy and julian worked on
um and there's also some commentary on
there i think from
uh from from peta from who who works at
google
um
about you know what the model is doing
um and i think in the samples he looked
at generally you know he was quite happy
that a lot of them seem to be
doing
something that you would expect in a
reasonable way
i mean it's distantly possible that you
write something that just passes all the
test cases but isn't actually correct
like we're sampling so many things like
this like it might be not not very
likely
so it's definitely possible and and we
did a fair amount of work um actually
generating new tests uh to try to make
sure that uh that that didn't happen i
remember
somewhere
maybe a little bit under a year ago uh
we took a dip dive on
our silverado and we were trying to
figure out whether it was the actual
thing or whether
actually we were gaming the the problems
and we realized that there was a
significant
percentage of our
solutions quote unquote
which were gaining the system and
the possible reasons for that were that
actually there was very little coverage
uh because there were many tests but
also the answer was always the same
right sometimes you have yes no type of
things and like you look at the private
test and the answer is always yes on the
40 private tests and and so you're
you're and so you know the the model
will try if you sample from it a million
times it will try to print yes right
that's that's probably going to happen
and for
other things we we just had
very very few tests so we we filter out
uh the problems we have too few tests
but we also mutated the tests
uh to to add new ones uh to make sure
that this didn't happen and i think we
we went down from
i don't remember if it was forty percent
or maybe even sixty percent uh false but
actual false positive rate
uh to
about four percent in in our final data
set which
is still uh significant but we we've
found that was a reasonable and
unacceptable amount of false positives
yeah i was i was i don't think i
mentioned this in the video too much but
you have this this kind of fuzzing
approach to generating new test cases
where during training you know the
correct like solutions uh so you can
essentially generate new correct test
cases by using the correct and solutions
that you know are correct which i found
yeah it makes sense i think this in this
space of programming you can you can do
a lot of these these things which is
neat right so what happens basically is
we mutate uh
programmatically the inputs uh of the
test that we already have and then we
run uh the human correct solutions on
them
uh and that if we
we filter these new mutations because
some of them might
not actually be correct inputs
and we we figure out whether the human
solutions actually agree
uh on on an output and when we have a
sufficient level of agreement uh on
on a given output then we add this
mutated input
to um the output that's generally agreed
upon now you you mentioned before that
you had high points and and low points
during the the process of this of this
project
again i can imagine that might be one of
the lower points when you realize wait a
minute all we do is false positives um
could you i don't know could you let us
in maybe on
what what was sort of the
the lowest point was there a moment
where you thought ah this is this isn't
going to work out you know after all
this time and what did you do to
overcome these things
uh that's a that's a tough question when
was i think the lowest point probably
wasn't the same for all of the members
of the team right because we we were
working on on slightly different ideas
most of the time
um but i think there was in the middle
of a project there was a
basically a month where
we had very very little progress and so
we had
these meetings every week when
we would see what was the best
performing thing and it was still the
same thing
um
so that there's there's that uh
there was definitely no point for us and
maybe like also when some of the big
ideas that we thought were going to have
didn't didn't pan out like for instance
when we realized that
for whatever reason
it was just too hard to train a really
good value function and we weren't going
to be able to to leverage all of the
methods that
this would have unlocked which
we did rely upon at least at least
initially in our in our mind map
so yeah that would be yeah that was my
answer
um i i definitely had a couple of
a couple of those myself
um but i think
uh in general a lot of the times we
realized that
we got results which you know weren't
actually true because you know they were
false positives
um
later on like we did claw back like a
lot of a lot of the the gain
um but i think that's just you know
maybe
the scientific method at work right we
kind of proved us like we tried
something and then we realized actually
um it wasn't working
um
but
uh
yeah i think you know having our our
metric
to guide us there and
um
yeah really really helped us um get
through those
i think we were well served by
a somewhat skeptical approach when when
we had a result that looked too good to
be true
our our initial thought was okay this is
too good to be true where's the issue
and
more often than not there was actually a
bug that we found
um
once you once you released the let's say
the paper and so on i think a lot of
comments started started coming in what
did you have
a criticism
that
like what what is the most valid
criticism that you've encountered that
you didn't foresee obviously you have
you have a lot of like limitations at
the end of the paper and you make it
very clear like this is one niche this
is this you know there's limitations
here is there something that
people brought up and you were like oh
yeah that i didn't think of that that's
a good good point yeah
there's a few things uh it's a difficult
question generally but there's a few
things definitely generally as we said
we've been very happy with how that was
received and we've gotten a lot of
constructive feedback uh
bad enough twitter thread is a good
example for instance where he outlined
why uh why he thinks and we do agree
with him that we're still a long way
from top level human performance on this
task was also made aware that the uh the
data that we we put on
alphacode.bitmine.com
uh was was actually not correct i had
filtered the the correct solutions wrong
so again
underlining the importance of doing that
right so i thank everybody who told us
well i don't understand this correct
solution it's actually not correct and
they were right so now we've fixed that
so if you go to
alphacode.dmi.com you will get
actually correct solutions hopefully
and then
something that surprised us but i don't
know whether it's valid or not is that
a fair amount of people seem to think
that the
average human uh competitor on
quickforces.com
is not very good
uh which i think we have we have a
fairly different view uh so i was
i'm i'm not sure i would say without it
but it was certainly surprising to us
and then in terms of the limitations of
the the model we
thought a lot and just a bit over uh
what we thought were the
weaknesses so i'm not sure that
i've seen anything that we hadn't
already identified
cool um
where do you see this
more in the real world we talked about
programming competitive programming
maybe you know a future where i can just
write a bunch of unit tests and and this
will it will go fine um
but
there are obviously applications beyond
this is there
is there
are there people maybe in your team that
are already eyeing
or maybe you have some ideas of
this where could this be used outside of
programming just the the techniques in
here and the methodologies do you see
some sort of semi-obvious uh transfer to
to a real world
problem other than coding
uh
i think generally speaking there's going
to be a lot of downstream applications
for
general-purpose problem-solving ais
to our team we've been thinking a lot
about programming uh and and less about
non-programming applications so i think
far for good there's some natural
directions uh which include developing
tools to make coding easier as we
already touched upon with
i don't know automated test generation
smart autocomplete etc or maybe tools to
make it easier to learn how to code so
you could imagine an ai that can comment
and suggest some improvements to your
code etc so ultimately
uh applications that could be used to
democratize programming uh are
definitely on our radar
um
in terms of applications not directly
related to programming
that's uh
i haven't thought too much about that
i'm fairly certain that
problem solving is sufficiently general
so that we will find interesting
applications but we haven't been too
much on the lookout for that
yeah i think um
i think you're you know you're right to
point out a couple of those ideas
yannick and i think um you know codex
has also shown us that um you know this
works um you can you know you can build
a product out of out of
um these kinds of models um and people
are really happy with it
um so
you know it's definitely something that
we're thinking about um
but i think we we definitely haven't
like concretely
um
made any decisions at all or or um
you know finished brainstorming even um
whether that's something that we'd like
to do
um
but yeah i think maybe to go back to one
thing that i remy mentioned earlier is
that like
um
[Music]
uh you know the the the methods that we
used are actually like pretty general i
find as far as programming goes you know
the filtering which is like the really
big one could definitely be used in an
application
um
but
uh
a lot of
what software engineers do is just
nothing to do with you know writing code
and like one way i guess i would think
about it is
what we've done is take a description of
like a problem and you know actually a
complete description of a problem
um and map that to code um but really
like you know i find in my day to day
i'm spending
maybe 50 or more of my time talking to
people and writing that description if
that makes sense
yeah al alpha requirement engineer is
the next is the next paper
um yeah is there anything you wanna you
wanna get out anything else you wanna
get out about this about this paper can
people
somehow you know get started with or or
get into this type of research or or
anything you you'd want to communicate
uh i think so we'd be really excited for
other researchers to to
uh work on i know
some other researchers are already
working on this problem but we
uh our goal is as many as uh as possible
uh actually uh work on this problem
because
um any any gain we make here is going to
be distributed so that's uh that would
be really nice and that's why we
released our
our data set which uh which we spent a
fair amount of time on and we think it's
a really good tool um to approach these
problems
um as we show in the paper you don't
need
huge models to to actually start solving
problems
so you can you can do that with a with
less resources
of course there's the uh
the issue of having to sample a whole
lot but that's uh i would say that's a
very exciting research direction to
actually um
reduce the amount of samples you have to
take to solve these problems
peter any messages for for anyone
listening
um
i think like yeah as as remy said like
the data set you know the fact that we
release the data set um is is
it's clear that that's like that's kind
of main point that you you should start
um
but
uh i don't know i think in generally i'm
i'm optimistic you know not just about
competitive programming but about people
working on programs and business in
general with machine learning
um so yeah i can only encourage people
to
to
to go and do it and actually have to say
that that's as a programmer myself right
like i'm quite optimistic that um
working on this kind of problem um is
gonna make my life a bit easier
um
yeah cool uh in this case peter and remy
thank you very much for being here this
was this was a lot of fun i learned a
lot and i hope to i hope to see i hope
to see the alpha requirements engineer
in the future
thanks for having us it was indeed
it was indeed very fun
[Music]
you